à l'entrée du salon de l'auto de
montréal ce kiosque du ca à québec
permet aux visiteurs de s'inscrire pour
tester une voiture électrique sur une
distance de 3 km jean-luc ga et gabriel
bodin en étaient à leur première
expérience
alors vous allez peut-être en acheter on
va possiblement effectivement enfin -
possiblement je fais pas pour toi
depuis quatre ans de plus en plus de
québécois choisissent l'auto électrique
il y en a fait 1200 7 sur nos routes en
il y en a aujourd'hui 8188 une hausse à
mettre en perspective les voitures
électriques représentent à peine 0,13
pour cent les véhicules en circulation
aujourd'hui au québec selmer véhicule
que j'ai jamais eu de ma vie
simon pierre riou a justement eu le coup
de foudre pour les voitures électriques
lors d'un essai routier au salon de
l'auto en 2012 nous l'avons accompagné
pour un petit tour à bord de sa nissan
leaf est avec eux qui est agréable à
conduire qui est amusant qui accélère
rapidement qui est très économe en
achetant son véhicule entièrement
électrique
il a eu droit à un crédit de 8000 $ du
gouvernement du québec
mais même avec ce cri dit ça ni son lift
lui a coûté 32 mille dollars
sauf que simon pierre rul 30000 km par
année et steam économiser 2500 $
d'essence tous les ans ma main on peut
partir avec notre carte du circuit
électrique et être certain de retrouver
une bande de rechange à proximité de
notre destination
un gros avantage pour ce qu'on appelle
maintenant les électromobiles east le
circuit électrique est mis sur pied par
hydro-québec et 130 partenaires
commerciaux ou municipaux il compte
maintenant 600 bornes de recharge dans
la province et l'objectif est d'en avoir
huit cents dans un an ce qui est nouveau
depuis l'an dernier c'est qu'on l'a fait
un déploiement de bornes de recharge
rats
et ce sont les bornes de recharge qui
permettent au conducteur de se recharger
en 20 minutes
donc les bonnes sont positionnées le
long des autoroutes du québec
la majorité des banques comme celles
qu'on retrouve au centre ville de
montréal met quant à elle de 3 à 4
heures pour recharger une voiture
moyennant un dollar de l'heure il y en a
de plus en plus la ville vise à en avoir
un millier en 2020 comme 90% des
recharges se ferait à domicile les
banques publiques sont surtout utilisés
pour les plus longues distances
l'ani 100 livres de simon pierre a une
autonomie de 160 kilomètres l'hiver
c'est encore moins lors de cette journée
froide utiliser le chauffage a fait
perdre 25 km à la durée de la batterie
les freins qu'on voit chez les
consommateurs c'est l'autonomie et c'est
le prix sans en augmenter l'autonomie
que l'on est capable d'avoir un prix
similaire ou plus bas d'une nouvelle
couche de consommateurs qui vont être
intéressés en attendant québec multiplie
les incitatifs les électromobiles east
non plus à payer les pont de l'a25 et de
la 30
ils ont également accès désormais à
quelques voies réservées pour le
transport en commun
l'objectif du gouvernement est ambitieux
passé de 8000 à cent mille voitures
électriques sur les routes du québec en
ouais jean-sébastien de 8000 à 100 mais
c'est plus que dix fois plus ambitieux
dites vous mais est-ce que c'est
réaliste
est ce que ces récentes quoi c'est tout
un défi parce que d'abord et la
porte-parole d'hydro-québec nous le
disait aussi il faut communiquer
l'information comme journal et ceux
rares sont ceux à qui j'ai parlé des
acheteurs de véhicules électriques qui
regrettait mais il faut convaincre parce
que l'autonomie des batteries est encore
restreinte parce que le prix de vente et
elle veille à ça et il ya aussi que
c'est encore un petit marché et les
manufacturiers ne construisent pas tant
de véhicules électriques que ça
actuellement le pays roi du véhicule
électrique patrice et la norvège depuis
deux ans 20 % des voitures neuves
achetées là bas sont électriques en
amérique du nord au canada s'ils québec
où plus de la moitié des véhicules
vendus sont au pays viennent du québec
mais le reste du canada ça marche un peu
moins aux etats unis c'est la californie
bref c'est un marché à ses premiers
balbutiements là dessus je laisse
écouter le chroniqueur automobile
philippe lacube l'auto électrique en
amérique du nord c'est sûr que c'est
très politiquement correct c'est bien vu
c'est dans l'air
on peut pas dire que les ventes sont au
rendez vous on peut pas dire que la
mayonnaise est en train de prendre parce
qu'on constate pas une énorme
progression des ventes
lentement mais sûrement tant mieux mais
ce qui est surtout décevant c'est de
voir que pop plus de nouveaux modèles
que sont dans le cas de certains
constructeurs on dirait qu'ils cachent
littéralement leur véhicule électrique
et on nous dit qu dents chez certains
concessionnaires quand on demande un
modèle et les cré eau électrique on dit
très bien veulent attendre six sept huit
mois la 2 1 2 1 s'est soumis moi
effectivement mais ça va évidemment avec
les inventaires par ailleurs rares sont
les concessionnaires qui vont pouvoir
offrir aux consommateurs aux clients un
véritable test c'est pour ça que cette
semaine juste ici où je me trouve pas
loin ce soir le salon de l'auto de
montréal ont fait on l'a vu dans le
reportage des tests avec le ca c'est
pour ça que l'association des véhicules
électriques du québec propose des tests
gratuits aux gens mais au delà ça
effectivement les concessionnaires
peut-être même parfois selon simon
pierre rioux que vous allez entendre
dans quelques secondes vont essayer de
vous décourager d'acheter électrique
si un concessionnaire ne pas le
véhicules en inventaire il va tenté de
rediriger le consommateur vers un
véhicule qui est disponible veulent pas
perdre le consommateur parce qu'ils
savent que s'ils quittent souvent il
reviendra pas donc on veut aussi de
l'orienter en lui disant des choses
comme le véhicule ne passe et
d'autonomie du véhicule qui pourrait
coûter moins cher en boucle les bons
2016 jean sébastien ça pourrait être une
année déterminante après décoller on va
jeter un coup d'oeil vous le vous le
montrions dans votre reportage très
rapidement mais sur la carte on devrait
avoir une précision mais quand même il
ya eu des progrès si le nombre de bornes
où sont situés les ben ça c'est au
québec sont fait un zoom sur la région
de montréal il y en a quand même pas mal
y en a moins que que deux
stations-service
évidemment il ya pas mal plus de bornes
qui en avait on en prenait deux autres
alors ça passe ou ça casse cette année
là
ben oui y'a sayah les services offerts
et vous allez voir sur les images la
semaine dernière en primeur en première
mondiale on a présenté la nouvelle
chevrolet porte c'est une petite
révolution dans le domaine de la voiture
électrique pop nécessairement pour le
prix de vente 30000 quoique c'est pas si
mal mais c'est surtout qu'elle aura une
autonomie de 320 km alors là c'est un
progrès certain pense que ça fera boom
au niveau des achats par ailleurs
bailleur un symposium international sur
la vie les véhicules électriques à
montréal en juin des milliers d'experts
seront réunis ici et y aller faire mieux
théo taxis les taxis électriques vous
savez qu'ils sont en test actuellement
et qui vont commencer officiellement au
printemps alors oui une année importante
pour montréal et au québec pour les
véhicules électriques
intéressant merci jean sébastien au
revoir au revoir